I am very very well right now because I
love this franchise and I love this new
movie I'll I'll tell you up top we're
going to run this when the spoiler
embargo Has Lifted so you could talk
about everything freely and I will
protect it with my life until the time
comes thank you scream has invented a
lot of terms uh you know face reveal
jump scare all that stuff comes from
these screen movies and they uh as far
as I'm concerned I learned that term
today the spoiler embargo I'm going to
credit also to the scream uh scream
franchise very important embargo to
respect actually this first question I
have for you is safe so as the new in
over his head cop in the franchise are
there any qualities of Deweys or maybe
elements of David Arquette's work that
you kind of wanted to infuse in your own
portrayal of detective Valley
uh that's a wonderful question what I
knew was what he had established as that
in over his head part is very key to
movie after movie and everyone loved it
and it worked great and Bailey's not
like that at all certainly as it turns
out so everything that he had
established David in his performance of
Dewey the small town cop
um set up
this character so I I had confidence
that that work was done
um and it was going to work in the favor
of the twit the plot twist all right so
getting into that twist now at what
point during either the casting process
or even the filmmaking process did you
find out that you were indeed a killer
and when you got that information what
were some of your biggest burning
questions for Matt and Tyler in terms of
how to play a Ghost Face Killer
okay let's I'll try to tell this where
it makes sense it's a little bit hard I
got the offer to appear in Scream Six so
in my mind I'm saying yes and I do
whatever whatever they want me to do
I'll do the agent says
um they need you to know that you're the
Killer
um but they didn't tell me which part I
was being offered to play so they sent
me part of the script and I start to
read it and you know especially the
psychiatrist character
he seems a little sassy to me so I
thought oh yeah well it's a psychiatrist
character so I'll be the psychiatrist in
the Scream Six then they send me the
rest of the script and then I find out
who the character is at the end
that's how good Bailey was hidden in the
script that even the guy who knew I did
it but didn't know who did it
even I fell for it so
still hard to describe it's hard to tell
that oh I bet you've probably been
keeping a top secret for so long now and
now it's going against every grain I was
well coached and you know strictly
Guided by Paramount PR publicity
Department to um tow the line on the
spoilers so yeah it's it feels feels
wrong but I'm even talking about it I'm
Gonna Make You Feel wrong again can you
tell me a little bit about working with
uh Jack and lyanna I'm not sure if you
you do this kind of backstory work for a
movie like this but did the three of you
ever I guess discuss what life might
have been like before Richie's death and
how they went from grieving to actually
retaliating yeah uh we we had such a
wonderful Rapport uh lyanna and Jack as
um you know spoiler alert the kids of uh
you know not really his real name
detective Bailey Etc
um because there was also a
said it was a third child originally
um that um it was it was in there but so
while we're shooting this final
confrontation thing a lot of us joking
around but really what the three of us
and others were doing was painting this
sort of lurid picture of how this family
really in all honesty was um processing
their grief
and our argument was you know you can't
judge somebody about their grieving
process
um in the case of this particular family
um they made some extreme choices uh but
so that's how we played it like this was
just how we were coping with the loss
um like of Richie I can't really say his
name it's incredibly effective
incredibly effective and again I promise
I will guard these spoilers I know can
you believe they have old footage of him
I I actually I can believe that I I
believe that Jack probably has whatever
he has and was able to give it